[Applause]
so I have a background in technology and
magic and magicians are interesting
their illusions accomplish what
technology cannot but what happens when
the technology of the day seems almost
magical what happens when you can do
this
[Music]
now hundred years ago
there were a fin de magic of levitation
is it possible to create illusions in a
world where technology makes anything
possible jump now if you know how the
trick is done where is the illusion but
still our imagination is more powerful
than our reasoning and it's easy to
attribute personality to machines
these are quadcopters but they are more
than mechanical flying machines they
analyze the environment around them and
react to everything I do advanced
algorithms allow these autonomous
machines to fly in close formation aware
of each other
aware of me mathematics that can be
mistaken for intelligence and
intelligence for personality
anthropomorphism that's the illusion an
illusion created by technology and
embroidered by our imagination to become
an intelligent flying robot a machine
that appears to be alive
[Music]
I think they say hello hey guys come on
and then Thank You Lance and that's it
thank you okay I'll see ya guys time to
go home
everybody in here come on ones everybody
quickly quickly
no no pushing everybody can fit there
you go a little bit to the left a little
bit to the right come on everybody
everybody and the chopped' thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]